the next data is publication data rob
can you tell us a bit about the
publication data so this data was
looking at
publication of papers that were
described in clinical trials
um the outcome is time until publication
and was a particular interest is whether
or not the
if the study had a positive the trial
had a positive result versus a null
result whether that uh led to a faster
publication that you as
one might think that's the case
or publication at all or publication
about yeah yeah the time until
publication wasn't linked until yeah to
uh the positivity of the trial
and so censoring if if
if
the time is censored it means never was
published never it's published or i
think maybe the the study ended before
the publication i mean
at the end of the of the data collection
the paper was still unpublished so i
guess this speaks to the bias in in
published
like clinical trial and medical
papers right it's trying to examine
whether there is such a bias yeah right
the incantation is pretty much the same
we've got time and status
the status variable here is whether or
not it was published
in this case
publication date is the end point it's a
positive result
it's a positive outcome if it's
published pause raises whether the the
the result in the study was was positive
or not that's that's the
binary predictor in this case
and we
produce a um kaplan-meier curve for that
stratified by negative or positive
and
sure enough
it looks
well the curves are pretty close but it
looks like down at the bottom here at
least
that
if it was a negative result it tended
not to get published in the you know
slightly
longer time
till ever or never publication
whereas if the result was positive it
seemed to be
a little bit ahead some of those papers
waited a long time they waited a long
time yeah
it's like the medians around uh
two years maybe oh my goodness yeah are
these statistics journalism no
statistics journal aren't that bad
that's that's that's a very long time
especially for medical journals
so now we'll
fit the same model using a cox
proportional hazards model
and
we'll we'll do a test
we don't do the log rank test here but
we just use the cox model test for this
binary variable and we see the p value
is not significant so in fact it's not
significant the difference
and the log rank test will provide a a
similar
conclusion
and
here we do the log rank test
and
once again if we put in other
predictors in the model
we're going to put all the other
predictors in the model expect except
the funding mechanism variable
uh why was that left outright i don't
remember
sorry i lost
in the in the actual lab in the book i
believe it's it's done both ways it's
done both ways yeah
so here we see there's a few uh
significant variables
there's the impact that's the impact of
the journal of that factor yeah yeah and
and that's
um significant
and
this is whether it was a clinical
endpoint or not right that's significant
and
and then of course positive result is is
now significant in the presence of these
these these other variables
so that's sort of curious and
this this often happens
there's there's often confounding
and masking in data and when you put in
other factors then the strength of a
predictor can actually come out
and that's what's happened here
and and we left with a number of
important predictors so the trial again
focused on a clinical endpoint
and the impact of the study and whether
the study has a positive or negative
result i see it was the impact of the
study not the journal